[Música]
y llegamos al momento de analizar todos
los temas que están ocurriendo en
ucrania ya está conmigo en el estudio
más romeros a la mar la guerra en
ucrania dejado y ha arrojado luz sobre
una de las polémicas más vivas en
ucrania la gestación subrogada que
sabemos sobre este tema mar pues raúl
sabemos que ucrania es uno de los pocos
países donde estas prácticas son legales
para parejas extranjeras recordemos
parejas extranjeras heterosexuales y que
tengan algún problema médico para
concebir eso qué significa pues que una
madre puede gestar un bebé para otra
pareja que van a ser los padres a cambio
de dinero actualmente es este país es
uno de los centros mundiales en este
tipo de prácticas y se calcula que hay
unos 2500 embarazos de este tipo cada
año eso significa que en este momento de
guerra hay mujeres gestando bebés que no
van a ser sus hijos que ya eran en
condiciones precarias ahora todavía más
en el contexto de un país en guerra y
que muchas además enfrentan un extraño
dilema no salir del país lo que podría
complicar los términos legales del
contrato que han firmado de este
embarazo o quedarse en una zona de
conflicto pues poniendo su vida y la del
bebé en seguridad y con la incertidumbre
que eso conlleva y que sabemos entonces
de esta mujer de estas mujeres
embarazadas más pues sabemos poco porque
sobre todo este tema trasciende a la
prensa a través de la preocupación de
los padres extranjeros algo que nos
habla un poco también de cómo son las
dinámicas internacionales de alrededor
de esto no la principal empresa de
gestación subrogada en ucrania barrio
text com publicó un vídeo 22 de febrero
diciendo que estaban ya preparados para
afrontar cualquier eventualidad en
palabras de tenis germán uno de los
asesores legales de esta empresa lo
podemos escuchar ahora
bayo text con clínic está lista para
proteger a las madres subrogadas a los
clientes ya sus bebés recién nacidos
aunque la agresión contra ucrania
empiece mañana tenemos suministros de
todo lo que necesitamos
y germanos
además hemos logrado comprar un refugio
antiaéreo cerca de la clínica para
acomodar a todos los clientes que están
en ucrania
vemos que están tomando medidas muy
fuertes para proteger estos no solo la
vida de las madres sino también unos
contratos y el dinero y el futuro de
esta empresa no vemos unos imágenes
también de un búnker de cámaras anti de
cámaras contra el gas perdón de máscaras
contra el gas en la intención pues eso
de proteger a madres a clientes que
también se encuentran en este momento en
ucrania pero indudablemente nos surge
una pregunta y es que quieren al final
estas personas que están embarazadas no
quieren estar en el según que quieren
irse del país quieren quedarse con sus
familias en cualquier otro punto del
país son preguntas pues para la que no
tenemos respuesta porque es muy difícil
contactar a estas mujeres si yo le tengo
otra pregunta porque la gestión
subrogada es una práctica tan tan tan
polémica pues principalmente la denuncia
que tiene esta práctica es que las
mujeres atraviesan algo tan importante
como es un embarazo con todos los
riesgos para la salud los cambios en el
cuerpo que eso conlleva a cambio de
dinero generalmente esta práctica sucede
en países pobres en india y nepal por
ejemplo donde se prohibió y ahora
ucrania se ha convertido pues en el
principal centro vemos que ucrania
y que tiene el 33 por ciento de su
población bajo el umbral de la pobreza
eso son 14 millones de personas ucrania
el salario mínimo son 155 euros al mes
entonces al final la gestación subrogada
surge como una opción para tener más
dinero en un contexto de pobreza pero
pues preocupan al final las causales las
cláusulas perdonan de éstas de estos
contratos no por un lado pues la mayoría
no cobra hasta que no se consigue el
embarazo no se prevén indemnizaciones
para la mujer si hay riesgos de salud en
caso que los padres abandonen al bebé
las gestantes tienen que dejarlo en
manos de las autoridades entonces vemos
que al final los términos legales
alrededor de esto a veces pueden llegar
a ser un poco turbios hablaba de dinero
marc cuanto puede a groso modo cobrar
una mujer que hace este proceso pues en
ucrania es mucho en comparación con ese
salario mínimo muy poco cuando lo
comparas con otros países den ucrania el
proceso puede costar entre cincuenta y
cinco mil dólares y 65 mil dólares de
los cuales para las gestantes son entre
11.000 y 13.000 en eeuu en cambio donde
esta práctica es legal en algunos el
proceso puede costar hasta 170 mil
dólares para la gestante entre 50.000 y
80.000 dólares vemos que al final el
grueso de esta de este precio se lo
quedan compañías compañías que por
cierto como buy o text con que de la que
hablábamos antes y que escuchábamos
antes está acusada de tráfico de bebés
fraude por inseminación de tener a
mujeres en malas condiciones de salud
todo esto en un marco legal ucraniano
que muchas veces deja mucho espacio a la
duda mar y todas estas preocupaciones
también crecen en estos tiempos de
guerra claro y sobre todo por la salud
de estas mujeres que son las finales que
están viviendo en un territorio que está
en conflicto y estas tensiones que
existen entre las decisiones autónomas
que podrían tomar ellas contra las
decisiones de los padres de los padres
que van a ser los de los bebés que están
gestando también de las agencias que
están pues llevando todos estos
contratos vemos que todavía se tensan
más y por eso también crecen estas
denuncias y al final la gestación
subrogada es un negocio que puede estar
por encima de la vida de los intereses
de la vida de las mujeres también de sus
bebés todo por anteponer los deseos
padres que pueden permitirse pagar estos
precios a mujeres que necesitan no lo
quieren necesitan el dinero para poder
sobrevivir
como también estamos viendo en el
reportaje es obviamente un caso
diferente las modelos web webcam